the weird thing is
is as you look at this stuff
in a large scale
all these things are in place
and you you know when you just were
saying that about vets
and you're on a bunch of medications and
you're
being basically subdued you know you're
being subdued
and it's not just vets it's like humans
humans humans are being subdued look we
don't really actually want you to do
anything
we don't actually want you to come up
with your own ideas we don't actually
want you to write your own freaking
books we don't want you to create
something what we want you to do is
continue to to feed our machine that
we've got working over here that's what
we want we want to feed our machine and
we don't want you to feed your own
machine and that that's
that's like what is actually happening
because people spend as i don't know
what the what'd you say 37 years in
front of a screen or whatever it was
yeah you're not gaining when you're
doing that that's not that's not for you
that's for them that's so they can sell
your they they can sell you to whoever
their advertisers are so you can buy
more of their stuff that's what's
happening it's your energy they need
your energy
see
everything is energy
they need you and i say they
okay like
corporatocracies governments whatever it
is marketing companies data capture
people whatever
you see they need your attention and
your attention is your energy and that
is the impetus for them to grow but if
you're using your own energy
to do your own thing
that's problematic that's scary that's
really scary scary for that right it's
terrible and they can't have everybody
running around so what do they want you
running around with a projection you
need all these things to help your
projection
and it is cr
this is a like almost cliche right now
it's cliche for me to say what i'm about
to say there are
free psychologists and scientists and
computer programmers or whatever they're
called
sitting
figuring out
literal ways to make you
look at the screen more
to addict you to that that's what
they're actually doing they're actually
doing that they're actually doing that
and here by the way you're paying them
to do it in many ways you're actually
giving them money to do this so that
they can get you to not think for
yourself and i'm not saying like oh
think for yourself come up with some
crazy no think for yourself yeah like
actually think about what's going on
around you instead you're just receiving
what someone else is telling you which
what they're telling you to do is
waste more time looking at this and and
and to buy whatever product it is that
they're making this is what what's
actually happening
think about like what have you ever
heard of the milgram experiments oh yeah
it's crazy right yeah what two-thirds of
the people killed the person because
the guy in the white coat told them to
right
so it's already figured out we already
understand how to like corral human
beings and to get them to give their
energy and focus into developing what
what whatever it is is vying for your
attention needs you it doesn't exist
without you
i mean our founding fathers were pretty
smart we the people okay
um you know
they understood that there is a power
associated with the people you know the
people united the people you know
believing in the goodness and the
opportunity that was afforded by this
nation and
and and instead we we have fractured
ourselves among the most trivial things
and then given our energy
and then we complain about the very
thing that we feed to build we complain
about it when we are responsible for
paying for the bricks the prison keepers
the uniforms everything and so
turn your attention to something else if
you took that same time you know between
14 and 23 years watching tv in your life
let's just say take one year
out of that maybe you get 22 years of
netflix in all right take one of those
years and and just solely dedicate it to
yourself
and if you do
well you will regain time because time
is accelerating extremely fast
and it's accelerating because
because time is only realized by the
experiences that are contained in it
right so like
like
you know i've heard it said like one
million years with one event
or or 10 minutes with 50 000 events
every moment of our life is filled with
it with with an experience and so we
realize time and time accelerates and we
accelerate our own time in life it's
like at the end of the day you're like
man
like you feel like you lived a lifetime
because you realized every moment of
that day and none of it was spent with
you
none of it and so you feel disconnected
right well don't worry take a vacation
down to disney
we're going to get you patched up
you know have a couple margaritas you
know eat four meals a day it's vacation
consume
right and so this built-in acceleration
that's happening that we feel in the
world right now
is caused because all of our energy is
directed towards that
and so i think that we can walk away